&gt;&gt; So the two numbers that we're going to need to help us with factoring add to
equal this middle coefficient but multiply to equal the product of the two outer
coefficients. Now I wonder if this works if we don't have an expression just
like this, where the coefficient out here is 1, in front of the x squared term.
Let's say we have something different. Maybe we have 8x squared plus 26x plus
15. Of course, the important thing here is that 8 is not 1. So our coefficient
in front of the x squared term is different this time than what we've dealt with
before. The question I have for you then is, what are the numbers n and m for
this expression right here? What two numbers add to equal 26 and multiply to
equal 8 times 15?